Speaker 1: All right. So here's the deal. My
girlfriend got COVID. We have no idea how. And
somehow I didn't get it, and we have no idea
how. So I've been waiting to tell this story
because I really wanted to be sure I didn't
get it, and I wanted to be able to tell you the
full story with some definition. So this this now
goes back a period of time, but I'm going to lay
it out for you the way that that that it all this,
let's call it, but I'll just use day numbers. OK,
day one, she wakes up with a sore throat.
We say, Oh, let's see what's going on.
We both take rapid tests and are both negative and
we just hang out at home for the remainder of that
day by the end of the day. She's feeling fine,
wakes up on day two, says my symptoms are gone.
I had a sore throat. It's gone. I'm feeling fine
on day two and day two. She says. I think I'm
still feeling fine, but I just, I don't know.
I've got I'm just really weirdly tired. I don't
know a little bit of a headache. OK, we go to day
three, wakes up, she says. My sore throat is back.
I'm feeling worse. I've got a headache. Let's
go and actually get pictures. Go get PCR tests
told. You know, it's going to be 24 to 48 hours
before you get the result. Later on day three, she
develops a fever. So now we've got sore throat and
fever and a little bit of headache. I feel fine.
We're waiting on the PCR results, but she's got
fever. We go to day four. Day four still has
fever using Tylenol to manage it. I still feel
fine now. At this point, we're assuming this,
this this actually could be COVID. Maybe the rapid
test on day one was just too early. Day four, we
get the PCR back and it says negative. Everybody's
still negative now that was taken on day three.
What would be considered day three of symptoms?
You know, day two, the symptoms went away, but
it's probably day three of symptoms. PCR is still
negative. Day four still has a fever. Fever starts
climbing 101 102. I still feel fine because she
has the negative PCR. I'm thinking, Well, this
is something else. We don't really have to worry.
We're sharing a thermometer. We're sharing food.
We are, you know, I drove her in the car to get
the PCR tests. We're sleeping in the same bed.
It's OK. Day for fever is still there. Day
four at night, the fever seems to go away.
Day five, she wakes up. I still feel fine. She
wakes up and she says, My fever's gone. I'm less
feeling like I'm sick, my throat is about 50
percent better. Maybe it's going away. All right,
fair enough. But then on day five, she develops
a cough and it's it's not a good cough. This is
the key to what would be called in the industry a
productive cough. It's a bad cough. I still feel
fine other than at this point. I'm having what I
would do. Some people call it a phantom, a phantom
headache and sore throat. Some people would call
it a Jewish neuroticism, headache and sore throat.
Some some of you will understand what that
means, but I don't. I don't really have symptoms,
but I'm kind of like, Do I feel something? Do
I feel something so? So now we're on day five
and because we, you know, still getting negative
COVID test, negative PCR, negative, negative,
negative, the sore throat, she says. Could this be
strep? Could this be flu fevers gone? Sore throat?
That productive cough is here, so we say, well,
we we need to get a flu test and we need to get
a strep test. I'm still feeling fine. We're
not isolating. We're in the car driving to get
the strep and flu, et cetera, et cetera. She
gets tested for everything day five at night,
gets a call back and they did another PCR,
just to be sure. You know, they test for RSV,
other viruses, flu, strep, etc. They say,
Ma'am, you're negative for everything
except COVID. You have COVID. And she says,
Really, I had, you know, multiple negative rapids,
negative PCR, et cetera, et cetera. I know
it's definitely COVID and you should be,
she says. Do I need do I need to isolate from
my partner, my my boyfriend? We live together.
And the doctor says, Yeah, you, you really should.
So at that point, I'm just kind of thinking,
if I didn't get it yet, I'm not going to get it
right. But day five, you can still be contagious,
even though she's had 24 hours without a fever.
And this is where it kind of gets to these mixed
messages. We have the new CDC guidance and the old
CDC guidance. If you without fever for 24 hours
and it's been five days in theory, you're
all good. But are you really? Do we know?
What about al-Muqrin? All this different stuff? So
we start isolating and we isolate for three days.
Sleep in separate rooms and, you know, wear masks
in the house when we pass each other. I really
don't want to get this thing. And OK, I had five
days of exposure day after day after day sharing,
food sharing, thermometers sharing. But we'll just
isolate for the for for the two three additional
days at that point. You know, she gets today nine
and still has the nagging cough, but is otherwise
mostly better. And at that point, I say, I think
I think I beat it. I think with the three doses
clearly I was exposed. I was exposed in the
two days before she was symptom. In theory,
I was exposed on day minus one and zero because
that's when you're believed to be most contagious.
And I was exposed on days one, two and three
when you're believed to be most contagious.
And I was exposed on days four and five during
which you're in general believed to be less.
And I just didn't get it. Now, could I have
had? Could I have had an asymptomatic case?
Yes. One that was both asymptomatic and was
negative on rapid and PCR tests. Now you might
say, Well, did you do subsequent PCR tests? I did.
On Day seven, we both did additional PCR testing.
She was still positive. I was still negative
on day nine. We both did rapid tests. She was
we were both negative by that point in time. So I
don't know. I don't have an explanation. You know,
it's I don't know that we will ever really get
an answer other than maybe it's as simple as the
vaccine worked. The vaccine, which when you have
three doses even against Macron, believed to be
75 percent effective against symptomatic disease.
I mean this this was not passing exposure that I
had, I think is the point I'm trying to make.
We were in the car driving back and forth from
testing into the hospital or the urgent care,
whatever the different, different places to get
pictures. And we were, you know, in the same
room and sharing food. I was clearly exposed
and apparently I had the, you know, the
neutralizing antibodies were activated
and I somehow ended up not not getting
sick. You know, you hear about people
across the hall from someone in a
hotel isolating one person has COVID
it, you know, Nicholas Kristof has told us
about this story. The person across the hall
gets it. It can be that contagious. I feel like I
dodged a bullet somehow. Five days of of constant
exposure. Really seven days. If you include the
two days prior to send him seven straight days of
full exposure. And I didn't get it, unfortunately,
fortunately, because we both work from home.
It didn't create any kind of disruption in
terms of work or anything like that. But
that's my story. And you now know everything I
know, and the reason I kept waiting to tell the
story was in my head. I was like, OK, what if
I tell the story now about how I didn't get it?
And then somehow, like, she's still contagious
on day 14, and then it incubates for five days
and I end up with it on day 19. You know, these
are on the edges of the bell curve scenarios.
It's now been long enough. It's been, you know,
three weeks that I'm feeling pretty good that if
I were to get it now, it wouldn't be from that
now. Where did she get it? We have no idea.
First of all, we we basically both have been doing
the exact same stuff. We go to the same places.
We don't do any indoor dining. We're not going
to the movie theater. We're not. Sporting events,
we're not doing any of that stuff. We didn't we
didn't really have any indoor unmasked contact
with anybody other than a car ride with
my brother, who also hadn't done anything,
had no symptoms, had no positive test before,
after, during. Is it possible that this is so
contagious that some of those other means could
could potentially give you the virus? There was
an instance where when we were outdoor dining,
she went in to the restroom with a mask on. Could
there have been a surface thing there? Grocery
store? I mean, it's we really have no idea.
And presumably not only did I not get it from her,
but we were both exposed to wherever she got it.
And I still didn't get it, so I don't
know, folks, I don't know, but it is very,
very wild times, and that's the full
story. As I understand it, right now